welcome to this new video by simply
learn before we begin consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn
imagine creating a 2 000 word article on
machine learning just in few seconds
obviously how is this possible to write
an article it takes a lot of research a
good knowledge of grammar and creative
thinking so definitely it may take a few
days or even a week but you can reduce
this to just a few seconds or minutes by
using AI tools chat GPT can help you to
design in-depth creative articles
whereas grammarly will solve all the
grammatical errors whether you are a
copywriter or an SEO expert AI tools are
proving beneficial to all the digital
marketers around the world with that
being said hey everyone and welcome to
the era of AI where AI is reducing the
human efforts by a scale of thousand
times in this video we bring the top 10
AI tools for digital marketing where we
will talk about some of the most amazing
innovation happening in the field of AI
and how you can benefit from it in your
digital marketing role let us jump on to
the topic but before that let me tell
you an amazing program by simply learn
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing will help you to
master search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and more
not only these skills but you will also
learn the number of tools like SC
ranking HootSuite Google ads Keyword
Planner and much more so hurry up and
find the course Link in the description
box for more details why wait for the
right AI tool for you AI is ruling the
world and you can create your own AI
tool by gaining expertise in Ai and
machine learning if you are willing to
do so then simply learns Ai and machine
learning bootcamp is the right choice
for you with this boot camp you will
gain expertise in artificial
intelligence and machine learning by
learning the top skills required in this
domain naming a few supervised learning
unsupervised learning recommendation
systems natural language processing
neural networks deep learning and much
more knowledge of tools like tensorflow
Keras matplot live scikit-learn opencv
and more will make you to stand out from
the crowd and grab successful
opportunities in the industry so hurry
up and enroll Now find the AI and
machine learning bootcamp program Link
in the description box so without any
further Ado let's begin with the top 10
AI tools for digital marketing
number one tool in our list which is
chat GPT chat GPT can assist with
digital marketing by providing insights
answering customer inquiries and
generating creative content ideas it
leverages AI to optimize the marketing
strategies ultimately driving better
results for business
next tool we have is grammarly
family can be a valuable tool for
digital marketing professional by
ensuring error-free and Polished content
across the various channels it helps to
optimize the written communication
improve brand credibility and enhance
overall quality of marketing materials
with its AI powered grammar and style
suggestions grammarly AIDS in crafting
effective and professional digital
marketing content
at number 3 we have word lift word lift
is an AI based SEO tool that helps
optimize content for search engines and
structured data it uses natural language
processing and machine learning to
analyze content and suggest relevant
keywords and entities at number 4 we
have can I rank
can I rank uses AI to provide
personalized SEO recommendations and
predictions for improving search engine
ranking it analyzes various factors like
on-page optimization backlinks social
signals and competitive analysis the
next AI tool that we will be focusing on
is link IO link IO is an AI power tool
specifically designed for link building
it helps in planning and managing link
building campaigns by analyzing anchor
text distribution tracking link progress
and providing recommendations for
optimizing anchor text
at number six we have HootSuite
HootSuite is a comprehensive social
media management platform that allows
you to schedule and publish posts across
the multiple social media channels a it
also offers AI powered features like
content curation recommendations and
social media Analytics
moving ahead with the next tool which is
mention
is a social media monitoring and
listening tool that uses AI to track
brand mentions and relevant
conversations across social media
platforms
it provides real-time alerts sentiment
analysis and competitive analysis
next tool in our list is MailChimp
MailChimp is a popular email marketing
platform that offers AI powered features
like product recommendations and send
time optimizations it uses data driven
insights to automate personalized email
content and improve campaign performance
towards the tool number nine which is
word tune word tune is an AI powered
writing tool that helps to improve the
clarity and style and tone of your
content it suggests the alternative
phrasing
and word choices allowing you to enhance
the quality of your writing and the last
one on the list is lumen 5.
Lumen 5 is an AI powered video creation
platform that converts text based
content into engaging videos it
automatically suggests visuals add
animations and syncs them with the
provided text to create Dynamic videos
listen to what our Learners say about
our courses in their own words
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learned present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University even though the
journey wasn't easy the pgp in digital
marketing with Purdue University acted
as not only a catalyst but a game
changer for my career change simply
learn because of its tremendously High
waiting to be rated as one of the best
Education portal online worldwide is
surely promising working for a few years
in the same company as a digital
marketing executive I switched to a new
role as a digital marketing manager keep
learning so here we wrap up with top 10
AI tools for digital marketing
you have any questions add it in the
comment section and our experts will be
happy to answer them stay tuned with
simply learn till we meet again thanks
for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you